we begin with breaking news from
Afghanistan where an American drone
strike has killed the powerful Pakistan
Taliban leader who ordered the attempted
assassination of Malala yousufzai an
Afghan defense official confirms mullah
Fazlullah was killed early yesterday in
Kunar province near the
afghanistan-pakistan border he is
responsible for attacks against us
targets in the region and violence in
Pakistan in fact he's reviled in
Pakistan for an attack on a school that
killed 151 people including a hundred
and thirty four children the u.s. blames
fazlullah for ordering the attack on
Malala in 2012 we spoke with the Nobel
Peace Prize winner about fazlullah one
year after she was attacked the man who
targeted you is now the head of the
Taliban does that scare you I'm not
scared of the Taliban I thought I might
be afraid of course and like dragons and
those things but I'm not afraid of the
Taliban if you kill someone it shows you
it shows that you are afraid of that
person so why should I be afraid of
someone who is afraid of me already
you know I quote that line all the time
when I when I talk to people why should
I be afraid of someone who's afraid of
me I mean he has ordered her
assassination since that date if he is
in fact dead it would be a huge step
forward in terms of Pakistani u.s.
relations and safety in the region he
has been reportedly dead before you know
but he but he has been targeted this was
a targeted drone strike against him what
I love love is the world will long
remember her and he will have been
forgotten by next weekend so and that is
a beautiful that's such a good point I
am always struck by how poised she was
then and still is today she's an amazing
young woman now that she's at Oxford yes
he's gonna be President one day I
predict that in her country